[Music]  more rights for shareholders means more  commitment to a company's long-term  interest a new law submitted to the  plenary will allow investors to have a  say in company directors pay some armed  groups and human rights abuses are  financed through the mineral trade in  conflict areas to stop this mep s will  vote on imposing diligence checks on  main importers of pin tungsten tantalum  and gold is your food really what you  think it is from farm to fork mep s will  adopt measures to improve traceability  of food combat fraud and restore  consumer trust in the food chain  [Music]  parliament wants ambitious goals on  recycling the share recycled waste  should rise from forty-four percent to  seventy percent by 2030 any PS also want  to cut food waste by half